[Musique]
parce que les français ont changé parce
qu'ils sont devenus plus exigeants
parce que le monde a changé parce que la
france a changé alors la politique doit
changer et avec moi
[Applaudissements]
non mais la main
je sais qu'une majorité de français ne
veut pas qu'une partie du pays soient
constamment dresser l'un contre l'autre
je sais aussi que les français refusent
le mépris social et la brutalité qui
l'accompagnent la france ne veut pas
d'un pouvoir politique économique et
médiatique confisqué entre les mêmes
mains
je suis une femme libre et j'entends le
rester
[Applaudissements]
une puissance d'argent je ne dépend
d'aucun lobby économique
je sème affranchir de certains dogmes
je n'ai personne à placer c'est vous qui
m'avez fait et c'est à vous seuls deux
jurés
vendredi contre
[Applaudissements]
semblerait une équipe d'hommes et de
femmes choisissent le seul critère de
leur compétence de leur dévouement et de
leur sens de la morale publique à fond
ce président sera aussi celle de
l'excellence écologique et nous allons
relever ce défi et rattraper notre
retard demain avec moi la france sera au
rendez vous du combat écologique du défi
[Applaudissements]
une justification aucun lobby économique
ne sera fondée à nous expliquer qu'il
est impossible d'agir et la première
décision sera celle concernant le
moratoire des ogm en plein champ et le
débat public sur les énergies sera
également immédiatement ouvert pour que
ses choix soient décidées par les
français et par russell
[Applaudissements]
aussi être celle qui fera souffler un
vent nouveau sur des institutions
dépassé et vulnérable et on l'a si
souvent vu qui se prête à toutes les
dérives monarchiques et à toutes les
tentations clanique et ça ça n'est pas
ma façon de voir la politique bien
nouveau
[Applaudissements]
une pré public de transparence de vérité
de confrontation des points de vue avant
la décision car l'autorité de l'état est
d'autant plus juste et ferme qu'elle
s'appuie sur des délibérations populaire
et c'est tout le sens de la république
nouvelle que je fais
c'est tout le sens
de la démocratie participative qui fera
son entrée dans la constitution
avec le référendum d'initiative
populaire avec les jurys citoyens avec
l'interdiction du cumul des mandats je
vous propose de remettre le peuple
souverain
au coeur de l'action publique notamment
aux fins d'assurer sa représentation
équitable dans sa diversité au parlement
la démocratie doit devenir notre vue que
les fuites au quotidien et je veux une
france qui reviennent à la table de
l'europe avec une europe qui se relève
une europe sociale
le rang
[Applaudissements]
dont l'objectif est de tenir sa place
dans toutes les actions de paix à
l'échelle de la planète
[Applaudissements]
ensemble
taux longs de la forme à cet élan
donnons à la france l'énergie dont elle
a besoin
j'ai besoin de vous parce que la france
a besoin de vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]